c'est au creux de l'été que l'ampleur de
la crise a surpris les dirigeants
européens 156000 migrants pénètrent sur
le territoire pour le seul mois d'août
les centres d'accueil débordent les
camps de réfugiés fleurissent aux
frontières dans les villes dans les
campagnes les médias s'emballent depuis
le 1er janvier 2015 plus de 500000
hommes femmes et enfants entrent en
Europe l'année dernière ils étaient à
peine 300000 l'Allemagne ouvre grand ses
portes tandis que la majeure partie des
pays d'Europe cherchent à juguler les
flux et repousser ses réfugiés venus
pour la plupart de Syrie d'Irak ou
d'éritrée près de 3000 personnes
trouvent la mort dans la traversée de la
Méditerranée pourtant mi-septembre c'est
la photo d'un enfant syrien aan qui
ameut tout le
continent branlebat de combat les chefs
d'État et de gouvernement s'emparent du
dossier à la clé 160000 réfugiés seront
répartis équitablement dans les pays
européens des centres d'identification
appelé hotspot seront installés en
Italie et en Grèce pour gérer ses
réfugiés seu la Hongrie persiste et
refuse 700000 réfugiés devraient
rejoindre l'Europe en 2015 selon le HCR
de quoi s'attendre à une nouvelle crise
politique entre les 28 dans les semaines
à
venir